hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
December 5th
2022. what's going on how are ya
holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] Year's almost over
Dude
let me shut off the heat here
I got it cranking and it's [ __ ]
making too much noise in my ears over
here
um
anyway yeah another [ __ ] year
almost over am I shutting this [ __ ]
thing off right now you gotta go over
here you hit off
and then it goes for another [ __ ]
three minutes and then it finally shuts
off
um holy [ __ ] what a weekend of football
that I missed I was being Daddy Daycare
this whole uh weekend which I mean if
you're gonna miss a bunch of great
football which I did shocking upsets in
the NCAA
unbelievable results
um
I was hanging with my kids my my son's
going through this this I don't know
this euphoric period of loving his dad
and I am enjoying every in every minute
of it so I mean if he's going to be this
excited to see me
you know something's got to give and
that was the uh
watching the football but right now I
got on the Raiders versus the Chargers I
took the Chargers
um what a [ __ ] beautiful stadium that
is I went to
um
I went to a game there like last year or
something like that I'm gonna be there
for uh Raiders versus Pats
um right the day after my tour and
speaking of the end of the year things
are winding down the film is finally
going to be finished that's going to be
wrapped here in about
December 13th my tour wraps on December
16th and then I'm going to have a bunch
of free time
to spend with my wife and family which
is going to be [ __ ] awesome I cannot
wait I miss the games but I did see
you know the results of what happened
USC inexplicably
loses to the Utah Jazz I don't even know
who they are the Utah something or
others
the Utah by yours
um
congratulations to them
knocking off USC USC Jesus Christ
[ __ ] blew it they're in the playoff
and then TCU loses
TCU come on frogs TCU like [ __ ] wins
when they need to win they win that is
the first time in a long [ __ ] time
I've seen them [ __ ] up a game even
though I didn't see it I saw the friggin
highlights the OLED analytics let's go
for it or whatever which I've given up
on because the analytics are uh are
proving me wrong every week I guess
that's how you play basketball is you
just shoot [ __ ] three-pointers from
half court the whole game
and you you know even though you missed
90 of them if you take six thousand of
them you'll score 120 points and win I
believe that's how the math Works makes
for an exciting game
Mike's Furniture you know [ __ ] pick and
rolls just just bring it over Center
Court and then launch it with nobody
underneath
um
anyway it feels good to have a [ __ ]
game on though
um so it's the first 10 days oh let me
finish talking about college football so
then all of a sudden like I wake up uh
Saturday morning and I feel USC lost
what the [ __ ] and I'm not thinking
anything about that that that knocks him
out of the playoffs playoffs because you
know
I'm busy right I'm not really thinking
anything and then [ __ ] TCU loses and
I didn't know where they were ranked and
then all of a sudden people are talking
like Alabama or Ohio State might get in
and I'm like what the [ __ ] Ohio State's
gonna I mean Alabama gets in with two
losses but then again they play in the
SEC
is that Fred balitnikov with the worst
[ __ ] haircut I've ever seen in my
life
look at this guy with a page boy [ __ ]
haircut 1450 to go in the third quarter
if you're watching at home
is that the new owner is that Al Davis
Jr belinikov
Hendrix
um fumble come on get on that [ __ ]
thing you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
see this is why I don't watch the games
in front of my kids
dude how can the Raiders suck every year
and have a uniform that good it just
doesn't make any sense maybe because I
grew up when they were great when I see
that uniform I see victory
I see Ken Stabler I see Jim Plunkett I
see Kenny King was his knee down what's
his knee down
no it wasn't
by the way what the [ __ ] are the
Chargers wearing you know they had those
great uniforms what are they doing with
these [ __ ] yellow pants
they look like some new superhero from
the 70s like Shazam it's the kind of
pants he would [ __ ] wear
on a date trying to impress somebody
yeah there you go buddy
that's okay it's okay you just [ __ ] us
13 to 10. yeah I know I know I know I
know I'm sorry
guy the [ __ ] hoodie sweatshirt he's
just not even paying attention
um
Anyway come on deep oh and I think in
the short field
Derek Carr Derek Carr Standing Tall in
the pocket goes to the corner The End
Zone touchdown Raiders just like that
go [ __ ] yourself freckles I might go 0
and 4 this week
um
anyway
plowing ahead here so then all of a
sudden I'm watching uh I watched
Michigan versus Purdue
which was uh was a great game through
the half and then um I ended up having
to do a spot at the store so I caught
most of the second half when Michigan
was starting to pull away with that
number seven kid just stepping in I know
he was sharing running back duties has
now just established himself
as a presence especially in the second
half was just running through
produce
um defense making that first guy Miss
Jesus Christ
when they overloaded that one side I'm
like okay I think they're going to the
left side and there was that one guy you
had one job contain him
he [ __ ] shook him
had him leaning right he went back left
and then that was [ __ ] all she wrote
um making that guy look like me out
there
so anyway
um
all of a sudden I'm seeing at halftime
Nick Saban lobbying as to why Alabama is
a two loss team I mean two losses
in [ __ ] the SEC is at least three in
any other [ __ ] I mean come on
the amount of Powerhouse teams they have
down there I know you other divisions
don't want to [ __ ] hear it but it is
the best football in college it's been
that way for a long [ __ ] time and
they have the titles to prove it all
right Alabama won like 90 of the titles
LSU got one uh who else got I don't know
who the [ __ ] else got one anyway Tim
Tebow
um anyway
and not even I'm not even thinking OSU
was even in the [ __ ] equation Ohio
State ladies and gentlemen somehow
I don't know what the amount of money
that that fan base has to bring in when
you stick them in the playoff that they
picked [ __ ] OSU who played nobody
of significance this year other than
Michigan and got the [ __ ] kicked out of
them
um got trounced
both sides of the ball got out coached
the whole [ __ ] thing so now they're
in it they backed in asked first with
the Horseshoe hanging out of their ass
they are now in the playoffs which I
gotta tell you as a fan is a lot of fun
because
um they kind of stink when it comes to
the top probably seven teams in the
country I would think that they're not
worthy of being in there I'm just
pissing them off in [ __ ] Columbus
right now I don't think they're worthy
of being in there but somehow they got
in there so now you got to be thinking
to yourself is this a team of Destiny
what if all of a sudden they turn it on
you know
because who's kidding Hill everybody
knows what's going to happen when
Georgia [ __ ] lines up against [ __ ]
Ohio State
it's not even going to be a game that's
going to be a game you're going to shut
off at [ __ ] halftime that's what
should happen that's what everybody
thinks is going to happen that's where
the money's gonna go
and that's what's going to make you
nervous yeah
I'm sorry I've been watching a lot of
Macho Man ready Savage
dude Nina then don't need them now yeah
let's start arguing with my wife and
after I make points go yeah
I did the dishes I made the breakfast I
brought in the trash pills yeah
um I'll work on that impression I know
it's brutal
um
but who's owning The Beat Goes On
um
anyway uh
so it's the first 10 days of the month I
think I had bronchitis
I think that's what I had
um I kept calling it Bill and can I just
rest his soul the great Center and
dentist
of the New England Patriots number 67
one of my first football cards I ever
got
um I think I have bronchitis I think I'm
going to say that that's what it is
um
because as an artist I don't have a
primary care physician
but my insurance doesn't cover anything
um
I don't even take the card out anymore I
just go how much is it just I don't want
to go through the extra [ __ ] 90
seconds to you and then shaking your
[ __ ] head
um
the only thing more frustrating than
trying to use my insurance is uh this is
going to be a hold this is going to be a
holding call
Jason look at this guy even with
vertical stripes you can tell he needs
to lose [ __ ] 40 pounds
um I would not want to get in front of
that guy with a head of steam there's
something about him something about his
[ __ ] profile I'm talking about the
ref
um oh this might be a hole in the
defense ah the old stretching the Jersey
um
the only thing more frustrating than
trying to use my health insurance card
what I've and I feel bad I made fun of
that ref he looks like a good father
laughs
I only cough now when I when I laugh
that's sad that's gonna be the name of
my next comedy album or maybe my
autobiography
which by the way I love when people
write an autobiography like Midway
through their life
I always wonder like what that means you
know do you plan on checking out soon
or like do you think that you lived such
an exciting life
that only hearing about half of it is
enough
are you planning to tap out
and that's the first dad and more
I didn't like that awkward fall
um
yeah you know what I mean
I mean even Keith Richards all this [ __ ]
he did I mean that guy could write 4 000
[ __ ] books he waited till his 70s
before he wrote One
granted it was 700 pages long
or maybe you just get an offer they make
you an offer you can't refuse
um
anyway uh Detroit Lions I had the Lions
this week I believe I believed in the
Lions I did not go [ __ ] come on man
if the [ __ ] Chargers win I go two and
two they cover right
I think they were uh I think they were
given three this [ __ ] Raiders defense
looks good though
um
anyway the only thing more frustrating
some point I'm going to get through this
[ __ ] idea
um the only thing more frustrating
then um
I mean look at the [ __ ] San Francisco
49ers are up 17-10 against Miami and
Jimmy Garoppolo is out of the game
figure that one out
the only more frustrating than me trying
to finish this idea and you guys is you
guys listening to it
um
is trying to buy the only more
frustrating people
they're me trying to use my health
insurance card is me trying to go out
and buy sneakers
you know I'm a size 12. they never have
it
which is fine I don't know why they know
they don't order enough of them
I go out there right
I [ __ ] asked the guy he got these in
a 12 and they always come back and do
the same thing I I got it in at 10.
oh great great I'll cut the back off
I'll turn them into [ __ ] flip-flops
like what does that even [ __ ] mean
it's two sizes too small
when do you ever come out with a smaller
size I could see if I was 14 years old
with my first little fuzzy mustache in
my upper lip and I was still growing and
you came out with the sneaker two sizes
too big and I could be like oh maybe I
can wear that in my junior year right
it's my puberty voice
you know
I'm a grown man I'm 40. I'm 54 years old
I'm a [ __ ] 12.
that comes out I got him in a 10. and
I'm looking at him and he's looking at
me like I'm gonna like well maybe I
could scrunch my old [ __ ] toes up
so the guy goes I go do you have him in
the other stores he goes no I thought he
goes you know what just just take a
picture of the of the the number on
there
oh this sneaker and just Google it and
it'll come right up so I Google it and
lo and behold it comes right up see I'm
I'm so old I still go to the mall
everybody I like going to the mall
you know going down there getting a
[ __ ] malt
you know buying a flexible flyer
to go sledding
I'm trying to think of old school [ __ ]
you did at the mall back in the day what
in the [ __ ] is Herbert doing
I think he's hearing footsteps
Herbert that doesn't sound like a great
quarterback's last name he is a great
quarterback he's going to bring Herbert
back
when was the last time somebody named a
kid Herbert
Herbie
all those H ones went away huh Hal Hugh
Herbert
Hanscom
um
it's gonna be funny when this generation
gets old and all those J names become
old man names
Justin Josh
Apollonia
um
San Francisco adds another three points
Justin Herbert just [ __ ] throwing the
ball in the general direction of number
13. that was the game plan on this drive
it failed once it failed twice it's now
fourth and five
bring on the punting unit
um
yeah so I I I go online and I go to
order these [ __ ] sneakers
and you know they show right up
I had my pick of of websites there was a
bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] on eBay you
know those [ __ ] that stand in line
these sneaker heads I believe they are
and they go in and they buy every
[ __ ] sneaker in there so it sells out
so when an old [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] wide right
why do I gamble
um
anyway I just realized I'm older than
most of the coaches in the NFL
foreign
anyway
so I find this website I go to a website
you know
I just feel like if I just if I just buy
them off some dude and he takes my money
and then disappears what happens
eBay is going to investigate what online
they're going to do an investigation and
what shut down his account then he can
create another one I remember one time I
bought a vinyl of this Prince album
because I follow Quest love he was
talking about this Prince album and I
went on eBay and lo and behold there it
was some guy in Japan had it
and I paid top dollar for it I came back
you know what it was it wasn't the right
album and he had my [ __ ] money and he
lived in Japan and that was it so I
figured at least if it's a [ __ ] store
you know maybe I had a shot so I ordered
these [ __ ] sneakers
and I don't know if I read it wrong
they took my money and I don't even know
if they have it in stock
I don't even I don't even know why I
even bought the [ __ ] things I have I
have more sneakers than I have space on
my I just have like three little shells
my wife has the other 52. that's how it
works okay and she has shoes up there
like
you know like you have like she hasn't
born in years they all do it's what they
do
it's just it's it's what the [ __ ] they
do all right
I have more screwdrivers than I need
you know I just bought a ratchet set
that had metric and standard I was very
excited about that
um
speaking of which I wanted to fly so bad
yesterday it was literally the perfect
day it just rained
on Friday
but I had to shoot something
for a buddy of mine and it was just
right in the middle of the day so I went
up there and I did one of my favorite
things to do other than fly is I go up
and I pre-flight the helicopter so
um
it's all ready to go
you know the next time all I got to do
is you know I do you know I always do a
quick once over but I I do the main
the main [ __ ] I get it out of the way
and uh then I can just kind of go and
fly and uh last night when I went up
there
there was these amazing cloud formations
and the sun was going down
and uh
I swear if I had more experience flying
at night I would fly at Civil Twilight
seems to be the time to go but I was
thinking the other day all I got to do
is just find out when the sun sets that
information is on the internet and all I
do is just make sure my flight ends a
half an hour before that and that'll be
fine
um so those are the kinds of things I
plan to do
old freckles plans to do look at the
rams look at the Rams covering
with a quarter to go
um down four points I believe they're
covering
um
that's what I want to do
um when I have this time off I'm taking
a couple months off
oh for [ __ ] sakes is that even defense
is that even deal with the liquid death
being held up I love it
was that look what death though is that
one of those mortabellos
no that's the meat
I don't know I know booze anymore
um
Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ these are not at the
beginning of the Season Raiders
this is such a classic matchup
these were great games when I was a kid
Dan fout's first Jim Plunkett
the [ __ ] charges would score a
zillion points and just couldn't just
their defense they had Chuck Muncie
at running back for a second they had
Fred Dean on defense and then I believe
he went to the 49ers how I remember that
I have no [ __ ] idea
but anyway it's the first uh 10 days
of um
of the month and I told you this is my
new thing I detox from everything
um I hadn't had a cigar since the end of
October but I actually smoked one
yesterday which I wasn't supposed to do
but I was in a scene and it required me
to do it
was either I smoked a cigar or I did
hedge clippers but the other guy was a
plumber and I felt like those were two
sort of working with your hands things
that I felt the cigar was
was funnier
but also you know at the end when we
were wrapped
one of the people there that worked on
it
Izzy was his name I remember that
because of Guns and Roses said
you know you want me to take that cigar
and I was like no I'll finish it
coughed my brains out
all right sorry
I had to go take care of that you know
because somebody wrote in and said their
grandmother was like 90 and she never
swallowed bad spit
as gross as that is I now live by that
much to my wife's Chagrin here so anyway
um
yeah I ended up taking the cigar and I
smoked it in my car and what's funny
when you smoke a cigar in the car you
know you have it hanging out
the window so you don't sneak up your
car too much and what's funny is you
drive down the street and it actually
ashes the cigar and simultaneously keeps
it lit because with all that air getting
pushed through the cigar it's like
you're taking a draw on it but what's
funny is if you get down to the nub it
actually starts to heat up your fingers
you got to pull it back in the car so
that's what I did right and I stopped at
a red light and it also ashes the cigar
too right so but I stopped at a red
light I took too many puffs or the light
was long one of those ones I had to sit
there for like two and there was I
didn't notice I had a little bit of an
ash there when I started driving I had
the sunroof open and it all blew back in
my face
all into my [ __ ] car
and um
I was like all right well I'll get the
little handheld out when I get home and
the handheld little shop vac thing that
me and my wife have had for [ __ ] you
for years we've said we need to get a
new one this thing sucks
this no this thing doesn't suck that's
the [ __ ] problem and you turn it on
it just goes like
and there's no suction and I don't for
the life of me I don't know why we
haven't gotten a new one
so once again I turn it on it's like
yeah so I mean you could get the stuff
off the seats but the stuff on the
console it just you know it just tapped
out so
I got to get a new one
um
but anyway let's talk about something a
little more exciting
was I uh
Jesus this [ __ ] defense is just just
non-existent for the charges here I did
three spots this week
and um I did two at the store and one
down at the Improv and
um I have to mention I have to say rest
in peace to Bud Freeman
um one of the legends
of the stand-up comedy
history the boom of the 80s
you know his comedy club was the site of
um
evening at The Improv
that classic Robin Williams special
I remember watching that and um
was shot right at the Improv in Melrose
on Melrose and uh
I remember watching that as a kid not
getting a lot of the jokes and [ __ ] and
being like wow what is this this is like
LA and Hollywood he shot this right in
Hollywood which is really fascinating
for somebody there's something about it
and I remember Robin said something
about bud and Bud was standing in the
back he was always in the back
and at least they always made made a
mention of him on um touchdown dolphins
um
you know and he always had the monocle
whatever they call it
um but he was a great guy was always
great to me
and um
I was really sad to hear that news it's
crazy too because like I sit there and
think like Mitzi Shore is gone Bud
Freeman's gone Lucian Holt's gone
oh listen hold I would never hold or
halt
um and uh Manny dwarmen
and I was just thinking all of those
[ __ ] Giants
that are no longer
um
[ __ ] weird thing man
it's a weird thing life as you get older
people just start dropping you know like
I've told you this a bunch of times one
of my my grandmother lived to be almost
105.
and she went through three sets of
friends she had her original set of
friends
and then she outlived like two more
Generations because most people dropped
you know start dropping in their 60s and
70s
and I spent every time I go over a house
to be a new old lady playing bridge
there
um
so anyway
um rest in peace to the great bud
Freeman thank you for all the stage time
thank you for creating the Improv
they created that whole chain and all
the great stage time I got
um speaking of great stage time last
night I went up at The Comedy Store and
there's this new chunk I've been working
on and
you know there was some bumps or
whatever but I've been having like some
of the best sets
of my stand-up career
I don't know why
but
um
I just think it's because my schedule's
starting to free up
so I don't have to like dedicate so much
brain power to other [ __ ]
um like watching the Chargers not
[ __ ] play defense here in the second
half
it's not really their fault it's it's
the [ __ ] offense can't get a goddamn
first down so they're the guy wearing
Mike haynes's old number
22. what do you know all right sorry
this is like extra distracted this week
all right let me do uh let me do some of
the reads here for the for the week here
oh look what we got here
undies meandi smoker [ __ ] say
undies me undies finish it in your car
the ashes go right in your [ __ ] face
he used to be white now they don't know
your race cause you burned your face
with the [ __ ] end of the cigar
but it's not going to stop you from
smoking the charges can't tackle
um all right meandies everybody who
doesn't love getting new undies for the
holidays
well I mean that's all I gotta be upset
but you know if I get a nice pair of
underwear I am pretty psyched nobody
that's hope let's be honest here nobody
over their certain age you know you're
psyched when you get some monies
meundies is your go-to spot for snuggly
soft undies and more that all your loved
ones will adore get married at matching
sets perfect for binge watching or
holiday your way however you like with
limited edition prints the holiday
spirit just got real man try me undies
and get 20 off your first purchase plus
free standard shipping and free returns
when you go to meundies.com spend less
time gifting and more time living with
the new meundy's holiday collection from
undies
and bralettes to PJ sets me undies has
something for every name on your list
uh shop classic plaids for dads holiday
sweater prints for fun friends and the
softest loungewear ever for all the
cuddly ones in your life available in
sizes extra small through 4XL
meandi says everything you need to make
your favorite people smile this holiday
season all in one convenient place this
is a great place to get stocking
stuffers for everyone you love Bing Bang
Boom knock it all out
and maybe a little something for
yourself too this year holiday your way
with me undies to get 20 off your first
order free shipping and 100 satisfaction
guaranteed go to me undies.com
that's me undies.com
beyondes.com all right
um and with that I think we're gonna
move on to the content here before I
start having a [ __ ] coughing fit
um
there we go there we go I just had to
get that one up
wait does Brad Pitt have a new [ __ ]
movie I'm gonna watch this
the Visionary the dreamer
all right I'm in
mind-blowing I'm already in I'm already
in Brad Pitt I got it I'm in
Babylon
December 23rd I miss going to [ __ ]
movies
went by the movie theater the other day
all he had was stuff for kids and those
[ __ ] superhero movies it's like what
happened to all the other [ __ ]
Fair the cinema is not the way I
remembered it
you know I was saying that the other day
like the job of the old of older people
is to tell younger people
that it's not as good as it used to be
that everything used to be better which
is so [ __ ] stupid right what you're
really saying is I used to be younger
and I enjoyed my life more before
certain decisions brought me to this
moment
um
why does 60 Minutes always have some
guest in a suit with his legs crossed
pointing while he's talking I always
feel like you're guilty whatever the
[ __ ] he's saying I I don't buy it
I don't buy it didn't buy it then didn't
buy it now yeah
um
anyway
um
I just completely lost my train oh I
know I saw this this meme or whatever
the [ __ ] you kids call them
and it said it was this beautiful young
woman and it just says hi I'm a new
artist and then underneath it was a
picture a kiss and somebody being like
all new music sucks no music was good
unless it was recorded when I was in
high school my wife left me
ah made me laugh my ass off and I was
like you know what I'm kind of guilty I
know I would never say all music sucks
nowadays
um
I just don't know where to find the good
[ __ ] but people when they show me it I
listen to it and I'm like I do like that
um but you know you gotta get you know
in in defense of old people I mean
Mumble rap
yeah yeah yeah yeah what the [ __ ] am I
let me come on is that just to annoy
people I liked how it got to the point
where I guess one guy was like high on
something and he did it and then people
thought it was cool or funny and then
people actually started going into the
studio pretending they were high in
mumbling
that's what I heard anyway oh Jesus
Christ all the time in the [ __ ] world
touchdown good okay knocked it out last
second
Jesus [ __ ] Christ so
um anyway let me uh
let me stop being you know [ __ ] you I'm
gonna be the old guy that I am
all right let me read some of the uh
well this old guy give you some [ __ ]
advice here oh also another another one
rest in peace the legendary Pat from
Moonachie
if you're not familiar with him
if you have a [ __ ] soft uh
you know if you get queasy easy queasy
easy
um don't go to this clip uh Google Opie
and Anthony the baby bird
um
they had this this classic uh
contest during the holidays it was the
eggnog drinking contest
and you had to do a double shot of
eggnog like every 30 seconds last one to
not puke was the winner
and he was
the year I went there
he was the defending champ having
already lost a toe to diabetes
um the man played the game
and he won he was a champion he was
funny as hell he was a great guy
and also an AC DC fan so rest in peace
to a open Anthony uh legendary listener
all right
let's get into it here
Monday Morning podcast
content
uh pulsic injury
all right if you're going to talk about
football for [ __ ] sake do a tiny bit
of reading
um why
[Laughter]
uh Christian Paul
pulisic suffered a pelvic contortion
from a goalkeeper need not exactly
flopping a word you [ __ ] made up and
used without any knowledge stick to
hockey okay
so a soccer player finally actually got
hurt
you know what I mean I mean first of all
don't even [ __ ] act
we call it flopping over here I don't
know what you guys call it
giving your team a rest
I mean it's literally pretending you're
hurt is literally part of of soccer
don't even [ __ ] so I mean how many times
you're gonna Cry Wolf before I'm gonna
be like even when you actually get
[ __ ] hurt I'm not gonna believe that
it happened
um
all right if you're going to talk about
football for [ __ ] sakes do a tiny bit
of reading I don't do a tiny bit of
reading about anything everything on
this you just give a [ __ ] you give a
[ __ ] about it all right
Jesus Christ every [ __ ] six minutes
there's somebody rolling around on the
[ __ ] pitch in agony
Agony and then five seconds later you
see the same guy running down the it's
like when Paul Pierce
got carried off the court oh no look I
don't know what the [ __ ] Final in two
seconds later he came walking back I was
like what the [ __ ] was that
that's my team I'm making fun of
look at the rate of fans bunch of
animals
um
I'll tell you this sir
the women play a manlier game as soccer
than the men do there's way less
flopping
way less flopping they get hit they
bounce back up I don't know what it is
I don't know what's going on with the
guy so I guess this guy actually got
hurt so my apologies
all right but you can't get mad at me
what do you mean do a little bit of
reading I got to read about every
[ __ ] injury
if I did a little bit of reading about
that sir I would find out that 90 of the
people were actually okay
listen I saw most salad one time on a
[ __ ] Breakaway whatever the [ __ ] you
call it a freebie a friendly he's
running down the [ __ ] field there or
the pitch or the Hedgerow as Robert
Plant might call it and this guy behind
him just [ __ ] just like a [ __ ]
I don't know what the one of the most
cowardly moves ever he just took his
cleat and just [ __ ] stomped on the
back of his [ __ ] calf
all right
and the guy kept going and he went down
and scored a goal you know what if it
was hockey after he did that he could
have turned around and beat the [ __ ] out
of that guy so that guy wouldn't do it
again that's what's missing in soccer
all right
why don't you watch a little bit of
hockey and see how a man's game played
all right instead of watching a bunch of
men [ __ ] rolling around in agony in
their goddamn shorts every [ __ ] three
minutes
Jesus Christ if I wanted to watch that
I'd Watch Sex in the City
um he didn't call me back where I know
soccer is a beautiful game I'm just
being a [ __ ] I wish I had time to watch
more of the World Cup I mean it's
actually the only true World
Championship I feel
you can't even say that about the
Olympics
look at the [ __ ] Rams the Rams are
going to win this goddamn game
um you can't even say that about the
Olympics because this all of these uh
you know
Peds and all of that [ __ ] they always
just seems to be
or even like back in the day when we
didn't let professional athletes play in
the Olympics and then we would go
against Russia and it was their pro
athletes versus our [ __ ]
amateurs there's always this there's too
much [ __ ] uh I'm not a big Olympics
guy
um all right coffee hobbyist
hey Bill I got really into coffee during
the first months of the pandemic I mean
really into it
I spent over 400 on equipment
oh my God
electric grinder
shemex Chemex temperature controlled
gooseneck kettle
Aeropress French Press I haven't bought
an espresso espresso machine yet dude
those things are like you can buy a
[ __ ] engine for your car for the
amount of money those things are they're
like two or three grand
I haven't bought an espresso machine yet
to get into milk drinks yet though once
you learn more about coffee you discover
that it's very similar to other Hobbies
like craft beer it's interesting fun and
enjoyable yeah and also highly addictive
uh the ritual of making a good pour over
in the morning is cathartic and like
meditation I mean I can't argue with
that
I mean I gotta be honest with you
sitting down with a cigar
you know when you have your right drink
you know the proper ash tray the right
group of people
you know
what kind of you know because people
actually know whether you go straight
cut or V cut or different styles or
whatever how you light the thing I love
a ritual that's making me want to have a
nice cup of coffee right now
um anyway grinding the beans boiling the
water it's a peaceful process
um you should take up a career in
writing about coffee because I got
relaxed just reading that ever since
then I only grind and buy fresh roasted
beans from the local Roasters in my city
and state to support small businesses
Jesus Christ is this who did Santa Claus
write this this is incredible I also
don't go to Starbucks anymore dude [ __ ]
Starbucks
could make a [ __ ] espresso with their
goddamn life dependent on it their
goddamn burnt beans that is the
McDonald's they're probably owned by
McDonald's that's McDonald's of [ __ ]
coffee [ __ ] Starbucks
um
I only go to smaller uh local coffee
shops and maybe smaller local small
local chains you should explore more
about coffee outside of a cappuccino you
might really enjoy it thanks and go love
yourself look at this person just this
person here
has figured out life
um why don't you help me out I just love
a cappuccino so much
um I've never tried anything else no
Americano or whatever I've never done
that I like an espresso or a cappuccino
um I'm sort of
parked there until I get sick of it you
know I I did find a uh
I was in a part of Hollywood I'm never
in and I found this this
um
coffee shop that was um
it was made from an old gas station
and they made a great espresso and
cappuccino
um
I don't know dude do I really do I
really need another thing
to get into
you know
because then I'm gonna go out and then
I'm about to buy this stupid espresso
machine and then I'm gonna buy the beans
and I'm gonna do all of that you know
what I actually I looked into it and
what I actually thought was you know
what I'm gonna let somebody else who
figured this out make this [ __ ] for me
and I'll give them my money
um having said that I learned how to
make a French omelette this week
which is um
not saying I do it well but I actually
finally understand the ins and outs of
it and I made three of them this week
I'm getting a little sick of eating
omelets but
practice makes perfect
um all right morning intake
let me get a drink here Jesus Christ
rage is just pulling away here
Kansas City covering look at this I
could possibly if the [ __ ] goddamn
Chargers
I could go two and two I could go one
and three I could go three and one if
somehow somebody gets hurt on the
Raiders and they stop playing
Max Crosby
that guy looks like a [ __ ] lunatic
if I just saw that I wouldn't if I just
saw what they just showed me of him I
would not have bet on the charges this
week
all right here we go
you know what I was gonna say maybe the
Raiders go into the prevent I could get
the [ __ ] back to a cover but they got
a 14 point lead here I need the goddamn
Chargers to go down and score a
touchdown right now and then the Raiders
to start playing more conservatively
which they shouldn't do but they
probably will all right morning intake
dear Bill I'm an MD and a nutritionist
I'm writing to say that while some of
the numbers the listeners gave you last
week about protein intake are
universally true not universally true
uh these figures can vary depending on a
lot of things okay great so that guy
last week who thought he knew all the
[ __ ] information
um now here's a guy who's saying he's an
MD and I have no way of proving that
um proteins and healthy salts are great
in the morning because they power the
brain and provide longer lasting energy
than say bagels or muffins I don't [ __ ]
with bagels and muffins
uh of course this isn't good for
everyone and they should consult
professionals on the topic of
testosterone this can be a strange topic
because there are different reasons
people
uh get into T replacement therapy
I'm already going to say this might be
one of the smarter people that's ever
written in on the podcast the average
male starts producing less testosterone
around the age of 35.
uh this is a general stat that gets
thrown around in advertising for snake
oil but is fairly accurate current food
and lifestyle conditions of the Modern
Man are creating huge deficiencies which
leads to lots of mental health problems
including mental illness doing it in
this manner is just as simple as taking
vitamins and supplements but because tea
has a taboo associated with bodybuilding
steroids and male rage people sometimes
get weary of the idea thanks for the
laughs well please write in again and
tell me about it
um
I think that person was mistaken that
every morning I had an orange and a cup
of coffee it's just when I was on the
road because it was a quick Health
healthier solution than to order
you know whatever crap that they had
like for the hotel breakfast it's
usually the most healthy thing that you
can do is get the steel cut oats but
they [ __ ] make them in a giant vat
three hours before you order them and it
tastes like paste
um and then also 20 of the time even
though you say put the Browns I don't
want brown sugar or put it on the side
they always dump it in
um all right
power washing video progression I wish
that guy could recommend some
testosterone
I don't know dude I I think I'm I'm
enough of a [ __ ] psycho
um I don't know if I need more
testosterone
or am I also making it taboo all right
power washing video progression
oh my God
I love a power washing video
um honestly
it's one of my I I
I've gone down rabbit holes and just
watched those things for [ __ ] hours
showing up somebody's walk that they've
let the entire thing just grow over
um all right Bill I've gone down the
power washing Rabbit Hole I have
favorite methods and strokes
I enjoy a good left to right than a
top-down finish
dude I watched those guys that that they
find those [ __ ] cars in fields
touchdown
there you go baby oh he's telling all
the Raider fans that talking a little
too much
Keenan Allen
touchdown is that his name
yo he's saying you're talking talking I
don't think he realizes he's still down
by [ __ ] eight points
I love it
that was not an easy catch
I like how quickly he scored that
touchdown and then immediately
started acting like he had a sock puppet
in his hand
right to the ground Emily stands up up
up up with all your [ __ ] yapping I
like it I like it he's pissed off this
is what we need
this guy looks like he's gonna miss it
um anyway
power washing videos let uh led me to
septic tank cleaning
there's a dude on Instagram I follow who
post all his calls to clean semit tanks
most people don't clean them frequently
enough so they form a crust on the top
oh dude I'm gonna start gagging
after he breaks that
oh gross
you watched this
what are you [ __ ] German
I'm trashing my own people there and he
makes the field goal 27 20. come on
charges
um they're actually favorite I'm [ __ ]
in this bed
um
most people don't clean them frequently
enough so they form a crust on top after
he breaks that he gets water flowing
again to create a healthy [ __ ] smoothie
I'm almost done with these and waiting
for the algorithm to suggest something
else masonry work or something dude I
don't know how you went from power
washing to that [ __ ] stuff oh my God
that's [ __ ] disgusting
I gotta take a break from that one who
the [ __ ] would watch that or film it
all right religion
is [ __ ] blocking relationships all right
I like a nice big statement
that's a good one that would that shuts
the crowd up now they're going to listen
hello
uh bellignorant Burr that's that's a
nice I don't know if that's funny but
it's definitely true uh love the podcast
and the stand up hopefully I can see you
perform live one day so here's the
situation I recently bumped into one of
my old co-workers sisters and was hit
with a bomb she asked if her brother
ever mentioned
uh uh she she asked if her brother ever
mentioned that she found me handsome and
cute
wait I bumped into an old co-worker's
sister
okay we've met only like twice before
and she seems like a really sweet and
reserved girl being a 22 year old virgin
I nearly fainted but I stayed in the
pocket dinking and dunking my way
through a two-minute conversation she
was all smiles and generally seemed
interested Me In Me Bill well why
wouldn't she be
come on man you got to build yourself up
there uh here's the problem my religion
only allows people to date other people
inside of the church
well it's time you left the church I
don't even need to read the rest of this
who the [ __ ] are they to say who you
should be with the thing is I've wanted
to leave for a year but I lack the funds
to do so
I'm a struggling entrepreneur still
living at home most of my family is in
this religion and who isn't
in is trying to get back in they aren't
too kind to people who leave so being in
a house will be very toxic especially
with the type of people my parents are
my question to you is should I still
pursue this relationship yes
and I would leave your relationship and
stay in your [ __ ] house and let your
parents be grumpy
who gives a [ __ ] it's your legs your
life it's now or never
and Jesus won't cry you a river sorry
um if it's if it gets serious I don't
have to be in a situation where I have
to be secretive or risk being found out
and be bagged through the mud I don't
want to be possibly to possibly break a
girl's heart by being selfish should I
just leave it alone until I can save up
enough money and move out no you know
what you do you live your life
you go out on a date all right you lose
your virginity not saying on the first
date I'm not judging her but whatever
you get out there you get in the goddamn
game and you tell your parents listen
I'm begging this Broad and I'm leaving
the religion
what are you gonna do about it
what are you gonna do
what was that there's a guy uh
oh the NHL what are you gonna do
oh you gotta go in there
I'm gonna have to do another bad Macho
Man Randy Savage
I'm gonna go bang Miss Olivia Elizabeth
and I'm leaving this religion yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] them
let me out what's the worst thing
they're gonna do they're gonna get mad
[ __ ] them
they're just your parents
you know
that's all it is
I mean so basically what are your
options can you [ __ ] cover somebody
um
all right I'm done emotionally with this
game I know I lost this bet um anyway
um
what are they gonna do they're gonna get
mad at you here's the thing when they
get mad you don't get mad just be like
yeah I understand it I understand that
you want me to stay in this religion I
don't want to be in this religion
um you know and I'm not going to be in
this religion and someday when I have a
kid he can pick whatever religion he
wants that's what I learned from this
experience
look at me I'm 22 years old I'm still
wrapped in cellophane
you know I'm Like a Star Wars action
figure still in the box what are we
doing here
and I wanna I wanna stick my dick in a
box there parrots
sorry
yeah
100 go out with this woman have a good
time
100 leave your religion and yeah do it
now
saving up the money because you're gonna
have to move out
you're you're an adult
all right you make your own decisions
now
you get with this lady
right and then you leave that religion
whatever it is
I would guess but I don't want to start
any [ __ ] problems
um
anyway that's great that's great just
give them a first down
these idiots celebrating after
everything that they [ __ ] do
literally caught like a five-yard
[ __ ] pass
um
he starts doing this these it's he's
reigning money at a strip club he
literally sat down in the zone turned
around and Dove three yards and now yeah
oh I'm sorry he's got the guns going
um well when I was a kid they only
celebrated when they scored a touchdown
they actually did
um all right oh bill it used to be
better when you were younger you're not
young anymore let the young kids have a
good time you're right all right
speaking of young kids having a good
time I want you to go out there I want
you to have a good time and you know the
opportunity arises you should bang this
Broad and uh you know if you don't feel
like doing anything else that's it
that's it but I can tell you this just
be totally honest with her
just be like I'm 22 I'm a virgin my
parents are in this crazy relationship
uh right with the you know crazy
religion I don't want to be a part of it
and I'm going to live my life so yeah I
want to go out on a date with you
maybe you don't open up that much that
actually sounded a little [ __ ] up
um
you know whatever
but I I don't think that you should be
like uh
in that situation I actually genuinely
feel bad for you so um
you know whatever go out with this woman
have a good [ __ ] time maybe she
doesn't need to know your whole life
story but uh you should [ __ ] just
leave the religion
you know what do you guys meet once a
week do you meet on Sunday
just start this week yeah I'm not going
because I don't want to because I don't
believe in it
what am I saying I'm saying I'm out
I still love you guys
I don't love that you've shoved this
religion down my throat but I mean it
seems to be working for you
it's not working for me
all right I think I've [ __ ] made that
point
um
anyways I taped the Bruins [ __ ]
Avalanche game I don't even know who won
that
um
I was very excited about that because of
the level of respect that I have
for the uh
the Avalanche I mean they're [ __ ]
unbelievable God damn it [ __ ] why did
I bet Kansas City I love Joe burrow
why did I do that
this is what it's like late Sunday
why did I take this team why did I take
that team why did I do this why did I do
that
let's see do you get no I didn't get
both feet in
um
see I think that guy you know doing the
yap yap yap with the sock puppet thing
for the charges I I never think that's a
good idea
you should score a touchdown and just
give the ball back to the ref and just
let them sit in their failure
you start doing that yap yap yap thing
they get pissed off you're like all
right [ __ ] now we're coming
you know all that vigorous head nodding
I always think that's funny when people
in the crowd do it too like they're
actually playing the game
Bill didn't you talk about that last
week I believe I did I believe I did all
right that is the podcast for this week
um sorry I know I usually do like an
hour but like uh
I gotta do [ __ ] I get my tour starts
back up the last two weekends and I
gotta get past this whole uh
bronchial [ __ ] whatever oh it's
another good movie what the [ __ ] is this
one oh man this is the Jordan Tammy and
George
George and Tammy
new episodes straight I'm [ __ ]
watching that step right up
come on in if you'd like to take the
grand tour of a lonely home
that once was home sweet home I love
George Jones
him and Tammy
uh Golden Ring
um I like that old school country all
right that's it
um all right this old guy that still
goes to the mall
and doesn't understand why people
celebrate first downs when there's still
eight minutes to go in a [ __ ] game
uh doesn't understand why OSU seems OSU
is like that that [ __ ] rich kid
whose parents buy him a brand new car
and two weekends later he's hammered and
wraps it around a tree and then you're
like yeah good [ __ ] him and then you
know next weekend he's got another new
car hasn't learned a lesson or nothing I
I don't understand why they're in the
playoff but as a fan I I'm actually
I I can't wait to watch that Georgia
King because what if they win what if
they win the whole [ __ ] thing
this bum ass team that's been overrated
the whole [ __ ] year what if they
actually go in and win
um
all right we playing the Horseshoe even
though it ain't shaped like it all right
I just had to give them a little bit of
[ __ ] there all right that's it what if
it's Michigan Ohio State in the final
I think that Michigan TCU game is going
to be a great game
I'm worried about that as a Michigan fan
because I don't think TCU [ __ ] up a lot
and they [ __ ] up that last game
um they also didn't pay the price right
how come they lost their championship
game and they're still in the [ __ ]
playoff like how does that work
um
by the way who did Nick Saban's makeup
by the way his [ __ ] nose was already
looked like WC Fields
you know what because the second he
thought he had a chance he probably had
his kids out there [ __ ] practicing up
in Tuscaloosa
um all right that is the podcast
everybody thank you so much for
listening uh another wonderful year in
my life of getting to live my dream as a
stand-up comedian so thank you to
everybody that came out to my shows this
year I have six left I got a brand new
chunk I feel like um
the Best comedian that I've been since I
started uh uh I don't know why but these
[ __ ] bits are just coming to me and I
cannot [ __ ] wait this weekend
to be in Boise Idaho
Salt Lake City Utah
and uh Colorado Springs Colorado
um I'm gonna be there and then uh what
do I got after that I got like New
Orleans San Antonio and someplace else
that just escapes me I can't [ __ ]
wait
um
to get out there and uh
see how these new jokes go I'm very
excited where my ACT is right now all
right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves and
I'll check in on you on Thursday